When knitting in pattern we don't want
to distort the edges of our knitting.
By taking time to ensure that the edge
needles knit and not pattern,
it will make it easier to seam the pieces
and to work in increases and decreases.
For example, when knitting tuck or Slip.
We don't want the edge
stitches to tuck or slip.
When knitting with a lace carriage,
we certainly don't want the edge
stitch to be an eyelet.
Preventing the edge stitches
from patterning is important.
Different machines
handle this differently.
Some Brother machines allow you to cancel.
end needle selection with a setting on
the underside of the carriage.
This is the Brother 260.
For other Brother machines,
the change knob
also called the KC knob, controls the
selection of the end needles.
With the change knob set to KC1
one, the end needles will automatically
stay in D or middle position.
For example, in this slip stitch pattern,
the needles that are
in B position will slip.
Here, I've set the change knob to KC 2
and the end needle is being
selected and will slip.
And you.
Can see how this will distort the edge.
Looking at tuck, the same thing applies.
We don't want to tuck
the edge stitch or stitches.
With the edge being plain,
it will  not only be easier to seam
that edge, but when shaping increases or
decreases, you won't be dealing
with a tuck or slip strand.
Because Brother machines
preselect the needles.
We also have the opportunity to position
any edge needles so they don't pattern.
Just position them into
"D" position before you.
Knit the row to manually
keep the edges clean.
End needle selection is important when
working in pattern to obtain neat edges
for seaming and for making shaping
easier and neater as well.